Don been nada the ESPN investigative
reporter hosts a back story and he is
looking at the back story of the
decision airs Sunday night at 9:00
Eastern on ESPN and Don joins us now Don
thanks for joining us let me ask you
what is was more over covered
deflategate or the decision because you
were involved in deflate gate as well
that's a hard question to start with
that I think they're probably on an
equal footing they certainly enraged
different parts of the country at equal
measure right New England was furious
about my coverage of the flake aid and
the decision people in Cleveland will
never forget it despite LeBron coming
back and winning a championship but a
good a good question both both upset fan
bases were than more than anything
do you know everything about deflate
gate that you want to know oh no there's
always questions as an investigative
reporter Dan there's always new
questions there's always new information
you can find out I mean we drew a
through-line as you may remember to spy
gate so much of what happened with Tom
Brady in that four-game suspension
traces back to spy gate and the fact
that Roger Goodell slapped the Patriots
on the wrist in that scandal and owners
wanted this time with deflate gate for
there to be an oversized punishment and
that's really what that was all about so
if we didn't have Spygate Tom Brady
doesn't get suspended for games I don't
think so no I don't I mean come on it
was such a silly scandal those deflated
footballs but there were owners around
the most powerful owners been
particularly like Jerry Jones that
really wanted the Patriots to pay and
Roger Goodell listens to the people like
Rooney Goodell hunt those guys really
wanted the Patriots to pay for
deflategate and Tom Brady and that's
what happened if I gave you one question
with the truthful answer coming from Tom
Brady Bob Jones what would I ask Tom
Brady I would ask Tom Brady how many
games does he think he won based on spy
game the spy gate scandal was far
greater than we ever knew remember Jeff
pash the general counsel of the NFL
was provided by the Patriots only three
or four Spygate tapes that's all the
Patriots said there was and when he was
given them in Foxborough Jeff patch
crunched them under his wing tips and
got rid of the evidence
and our story that I did back with Seth
what regime they were referring to there
was at least 40 games that the Patriots
used spying techniques so I would ask
Tom Brady how many games did you win did
you win a Super Bowl based on
information given to you through spying
on opposing team signals I remember the
last time the Commissioner was on this
show that might have been how many years
ago bowling like seven seven or eight
seven or eight and I said why would you
destroy tapes spike he goes well there's
no reason for him and I I'm thinking
okay like it was such a strange answer
that he was like of course we destroy it
I I don't know don't they have a storage
bin where they keep all the things that
you know or NFL films would want
something like this absolutely and
remember the NFL took the word of the
Patriots this that this was the only
evidence of this scandal
there was really no real investigation
that was ever conducted a spy gate it
was wrapped up within a week they just
wanted it to go away
and this was only the first year of
Roger Goodell Commissioner ship and Bob
Kraft the owner of the Patriots helped
Goodell get his job the whole thing's
done all right the reason why we're
having your on is back story of the
decision that airs this Sunday night at
9:00 Eastern I'm looking at a quote here
with Dwayne Wade Dwyane Wade telling
Rachel Nichols of ESPN LeBron kind of
went into his cave went radio silent
kind of had to deal with his own process
but we were a little nervous on the
other side like wait are we still in
this did Dwyane Wade know that LeBron
was coming to Miami
sounds like a cover story doesn't it
what Dwayne told Rachel Nichols these
guys had talked about playing together
way back in 2006 when Dwyane Wade Chris
Bosh and LeBron James were teammates on
the world championships team and again
in 2008 when there were teammates on the
Olympics team they could have signed
five-year max deals instead all three of
them signed three-year rookie extensions
which made them eligible free agent for
free agents
in 2010 we looked into a Dan I can't
prove unequivocally that that night when
Dwayne Wade was tuning in he really
didn't know what LeBron was going to do
but the day before the decision remember
Chris Bosh said I'm gonna play for the
Miami Heat with Dwyane Wade and a lot of
insiders are like alright that's all the
proof we need that tomorrow night on the
decision LeBron James is gonna say I'm
going to Miami I what's the one thing
that'll stand out more than anything
else that you found out the the back
story of the decision well you know
there's a lot of new information in our
show Dan but one of the things that I so
love about what we found out is the
origin story you know Jim Gray was the
host as you may remember the veteran
broadcaster he had said it was his idea
that he raised it with Ari Emanuel the
Hollywood agent and maverick Carter in
June of 2010 during the NBA Finals Game
two at half time in LA it turns out
actually the idea was from a guy named
drew in Columbus Ohio in November 2009
he wrote a letter to Bill Simmons his
mailbag column of espn.com and said what
if LeBron had announced would announce
his decision his free agency decision
live on ABC Bill Simmons responded in
that column and said great idea LeBron
should put it on pay-per-view and then
Bill Simmons took the idea pitched it in
February
if the all-star weekend in Dallas to
Maverick Carter LeBron's business
partner Leon Rose LeBrons agent
worldwide West
LeBron's advisor at the time he also
Simmons also pitched it to ESPN
executives as four months Simmons was
trying to basically get this show done
and then sort of in a moment of
serendipity I guess maverick Carter Ari
Emanuel and Jim Gray are at the all-star
game all right Brett the NBA Finals I
should say and come up with this idea so
what what really happened there and
whose idea it was is really fascinating
but the other part of it Dan is just a
revolution was going on that night we
saw a bad hour of TV an awkward hour of
TV
this was LeBron and maverick Carter
becoming producers taking control of
their own storytelling in a remarkable
way really because you look at it now
ten years later the through line that
you draw an uninterrupted a Springhill
entertainment just this week just yes
today bloomberg reported a hundred
million dollars is being raised for
storytelling by black artists through
LeBron and Mavericks media company and
this was them look it was a it was
probably a good idea really badly
executed they made a lot of mistakes
that night it was some bad TV but they
were spreading their wings and trying
this out and now you know arguably
LeBron is the most influential outspoken
athlete in the country and what he's
doing with his storytelling through
these various shows that he does and as
an executive producer is really
remarkable who decided how long they
were gonna wait before LeBron made the
decision well LeBron and maverick Carter
were the producers of the show though I
interviewed John skipper the former
president of ESPN who greenlit the show
and Vince Torre the head of the news
division of ESPN you know they say the
only way to hold an audience is to you
know kill some time it's a one-hour show
wasn't until nine twenty eight Eastern
that Jim very finally got around to
asking what's your decision
that's after twenty three questions by
the way Dan including are you a nail
biter and did you bring the powder so
there was a lot of time killing going on
I think ESPN partly had some motive
there but a lot of this was maverick
Carter in Jim Gray they were really in
control the cameras got turned on they
belonged to ESPN and the satellite
uplink belong to ESPN but it was really
maverick carter and jim gray calling the
shots that night but did you talk to Jon
skipper and Vince Dory about their role
of because Jim Gray wasn't working for
ESPN but so this is right
ESPN executives did they have any
control over when Jim Gray was going to
ask LeBron what's his decision well it's
interesting they had some they say they
certainly understood what was going on
but no really they say this was a
maverick Carter production remember ESPN
was bait don't basically donated that
out gave maverick Carter LeBron James a
tower for free so an hour of free
television on ESPN was traded for an
exclusive and so you know an old-school
journalist like me at the time I was at
the New York Times I thought there's
something wrong there
you know I don't like the way this looks
and with both Doria and skipper if you
watch the show on Sunday night they sort
of justify it they understand it from a
TV perspective why LeBron and maverick
and Jim Gray did what they did how do
they keep it quiet like how many people
knew that where LeBron was going well
very few I knew about it and and that
was another interesting thing right you
had these ESPN insiders like Chris
Broussard tasked with trying to find out
where LeBron was going and if they did
find out big scoop their own network and
I asked skipper about that and Dorrie
about that as well
a very small circle of people knew
LeBron said that night in the chair that
he didn't make the decision so that
morning after he spoke with his mother
and he said that the number of people
that knew the decision as he sat in the
chair was you could count it on one hand
now again whether D Wade and Chris Bosh
and others Pat Riley the people in Miami
knew more than that they probably did I
would guess and we we delve into that a
little bit but how they kept it secret
it is it is pretty remarkable when you
consider in this day and age how nothing
that has ever known by anybody stays a
secret for very long did Jim Gray no I
don't think Jim Gray knew I really don't
you know there was very little
preparation one of the things we found
out is LeBron wood is was at his
basketball camp that week in Akron he
didn't arrive in Greenwich until about
six o'clock that night just a few hours
before the decision broadcast people
around LeBron told me he had no idea
there were gonna be so many questions I
mean you see him in the chair it's so
awkward but he also looks so
uncomfortable almost as if in the moment
he's thinking this is this is a bad idea
the other thing Dan we found out is that
Leon Rose LeBrons agent at the time and
worldwide West both warned people around
LeBron and his inner circle that this
had the potential of backfire they knew
that he was not going to stay in
Cleveland and they knew if you announce
I'm leaving my hometown on national
television with 10 million people
watching there was a lot of potential
for an enormous backlash and
undercutting your brand why Greenwich
Connecticut for the announcement okay
that that's a
very good question that I am almost
certain this is the right answer
Keith Clinkscale zat executive at ESPN
at the time and the liaison between the
LeBron camp and the network I believe
Rena CH for its proximity to Bristol of
course I'm a long suffering Knicks fans
so when I heard Greenwich okay you know
it was like the mother of all head
states right yes but but I think it
really was that but you know the whole
look of it I heard you guys talking
about it before the break I mean
Greenwich Connecticut the criticism was
even to the kids in the background
critics said they were used as props you
know the garage the Greenwich
Connecticut Boys and Girls Club you know
looks like a country club compared to a
lot of the Boys and Girls Clubs around
the country so even the backdrop just
just didn't work nothing worked that
night what's the next story you want to
dive into so we have already begun we've
done a lot of interviews and we're
really excited about our next back story
it's the man's idea a catfishing scandal
and we're delving into that we hope to
have that done later this year
a lot of unanswered questions there how
much did manti te'o know what did he
know when when did he know it I guess is
what I'm trying to find out I think
viewers gonna be really surprised and
will enjoy that did he cooperate no he
hasn't yet that's him yet still trying
but he knows we're on the hunt did you
interview is girlfriend you meet his
fake dead girlfriend yes that'd be a
great get the fake people try your
investigative reporter my love that's
right Don thank you we'll look forward
to that on Sunday night thank you Dad
great to be with you Don Van Natta ESPN
investigative reporter and host of back
story that comes out this Sunday night
at 9:00 Eastern the decision